[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
one of the things I've talked about on
the show and that I often talk about
when I speak to students either in
classes I'm teaching or where I'm
lecturing elsewhere is the idea of bias
by story selection and the concept that
the stories were even aware of in a
particular day if we consume any news at
all and not everybody does represent
this tiny portion some point zero zero
zero I don't know how many zero one
percent of all the stories that we could
have heard about all of the stuff that
happened in a particular day on our
planet and it's really important to
understand why that is and sometimes
it's because of bias the sensationalism
sometimes it's because of advertiser
bias or corporate bias or bias to
availability right the idea that we hear
from the Pentagon on most days on every
cable channel not because there's
actually news from the Pentagon on every
single day but because most news
channels have somebody at the Pentagon
they've got them there already so it's
way cheaper and easier to report
so-called news from that location than
from some other where you might not be
set up so this gets us to a terror
attempt that took place last week at an
airport in the United States you might
be saying well hold on wait what are you
talking about I didn't hear about that
you didn't hear about it because there
was effectively no coverage of it
whatsoever there was silence on this
issue from our president Donald Trump
who usually is very quick to try to take
advantage of any attempted or successful
terrorist attacks to push some or other
harebrained policy and the details of
the story are as follows an Asheville
North Carolina's Airport not long after
midnight on a late night last week a man
who is wearing all black walked into the
terminal was seen on security footage
coming in with a bag and then leaving
without the bag this immediately raised
the suspicions of airport security a
bomb sniffing dog was brought out
sniffed the bag and signaled that there
was something explosive within it and
indeed a I'm sorry aan
Oh which is ammonium nitrate fuel oil
was found inside of it that's a kind of
explosive which according to the
criminal complaint has been used in a
number of terrorist related incidents
around the world and the way that that
material works is that when an ignition
source comes into contact with it it
violently explodes it's a bomb
sometimes metal will be added to the
bomb to create shrapnel and increase the
physical harm that it causes right you
could do sharp nails or bullets or other
stuff both sharp nails and bullets were
actually found in this bomb now again
you're probably hearing me say this and
you're thinking David that's major an
attempted terrorist attack with a
shrapnel Laden bomb found in an American
Airport and we didn't hear about it will
the alarm on the bomb was scheduled to
go off at 6:00 a.m. meaning that this
was found a few hours before it actually
exploded the man in question was found
he openly admitted to authorities that
he was preparing to quote fight a war on
US soil a bomb against whom and on whose
behalf we don't actually know so why
didn't we hear about it now it's very
easy to say well David we didn't hear
about it because it was foiled wrong we
hear about foiled attacks all the time
but it depends on the particulars of the
attack and of the would-be perpetrator
this was just another American white guy
what if this foiled attack with a
shrapnel Laden bomb at an American
Airport had been Muslim that would then
have been reported and used this
justification for the travel ban by the
President of the United States what if
this would-be perpetrator had been
Hispanic well then it would have been
justification for the wall with Mexico
because some I'm sure are good people
but they're not exactly sending us our
best but it was just your average
American white guy who was his war even
against I don't know but he was one of
these white militia types that we've
been hearing more and more about from
groups that track extremists like the
anti-defamation league so the
fundamental point to be made here is
that if you make a big deal out of this
foiled terrorist
attack by just an American white guy it
doesn't advance any political agenda our
safety agenda would benefit from us
realizing that it's mostly white
Americans who commit terror in the
United States the safety agenda would be
advanced by realizing that the political
agenda of the American right is advanced
only when there is a pretext right
Muslims Hispanics whatever if the
incident foiled or successful can
provide a pretext for legislation that
the right wants to pass that's when we
hear about it and it's very popular to
frame the threat as an external one that
we can insulate ourselves against if we
keep the right people out of the country
but once again it's not and again you
didn't hear about this because it did
not serve the current administration's
political agenda there's a funny and
scary article from Eric Levitz in New
York Magazine and he's pointing out
something that we've been reporting on
piecemeal for several months which is
that Donald Trump seems to become
enraged when there is accurate reporting
about the impact of the legislation he
wants passed so forget about low
information voters who are falling for
this stuff we have maybe our lowest ever
information president and the main point
is Donald Trump doesn't know what his
policies are going to do or what his
proposals are going to do he signs off
on stuff maybe because someone five
minutes prior told him it was going to
be a good idea later he starts seeing
reporting about what the impact of his
policies would be and he ends up furious
usually with someone I guess whoever
suggested to him these ideas in the
first place so I'll give you some
examples right the Obamacare repeal
promise that he and many other
Republicans made during the campaign
that turned into the Republicans have
proposed a mean bill well yeah and
Donald Trump ended up furious with the
accurate coverage of what would happen
to people's health care if Trump care I
believe at the time 1.0 was enacted
and Obamacare repealed Trump campaigned
on I'm going to have a tax plan that's
going to be really really great for the
middle class he publishes the tax plan
and then the analyses accurately say
hold on a second this is a major
giveaway for the richest of all
Americans this is really going to do
nothing for the middle class it'll be
great for people with gigantic estates
accurate coverage Trump furious about
how the coverage is going because he's
just learning what the impact of his
policy is going to be another example
from the tax proposal Trump was fully on
board with this idea of repealing the
deductibility of state and local taxes
at the federal level everybody who has
some economic sense flips out and tells
Trump you know that that's terrible for
the middle class and now Trump is
furious and he has come out against the
elimination of that tax deductibility
for the state and local tax and an
important discussion that we have to
have when we talk about this is it's
very easy and I know I've talked about
is Trump suffering from the early stages
of dementia does Trump have Alzheimer's
this Trump have limited cognition or
limited ability to read it becomes sort
of an easy out in a way because it
excuses Donald Trump being genuinely
clueless and in over his head and it
excuses those who voted for Donald Trump
right because if we just write off the
the total lack of connection to the
real-world impact of Donald Trump's
policies if we say it's not because he's
a genuinely selfish and bad guy it's not
because he's in way over his head if we
say it's it's dementia or Alzheimer's
we're excusing those who voted for
Donald Trump and we shouldn't be doing
that they don't deserve to be excused
for having put this guy in the Oval
Office and I don't know the reality of
the possible diagnosis of Donald Trump
whether it is limited literacy or
Alzheimer's or dementia or whatever the
case may be but the problem here is
under the under the understanding that
Donald Trump is not currently senile he
is clueless on policy and appears to
genuinely not be a good per
there's a conversation I saw from an
interview recently that Donald Trump did
with Forbes is Randal Lane and it's an
example of this total lack of
understanding that doesn't seem to be
dementia or Alzheimer's and the
conversation that they had is one where
Randal Lane said about Donald Trump's
tax plan so it's a massive tax cut but
then that runs against your pledge to
not increase the deficit because you
can't you know and Trump says no because
no because a tax cut will spur growth
and Lane says yes that is true and there
is dynamic scoring and Trump adds the
growth the growth will be so much that
it'll be and lane interrupts and says
yeah but history has shown that you
can't just cut it does spur growth but
it won't pay for itself history has
shown that and Donald Trump says well
history has also shown the opposite I
mean you've had it both ways it has
shown both ways so Donald Trump then
tries to come up with an example of when
tax cuts have been economically
stimulative above and beyond the
decreased revenue and he says well
during Reagan he tremendous growth and
Lane accurately points out there was
growth but it ballooned the deficit I
want to think through an example here
because if you just put in two minutes
of time into thinking about this idea if
you cut taxes for the rich does it
really spur enough growth to make up for
the loss government revenue imagine an
economy that is ten thousand dollars
okay the total economy is ten thousand
dollars you want to cut the tax rate
let's say from 40 percent to 30 percent
okay so at a forty percent tax rate in
your ten thousand dollar economy that's
four thousand dollars in tax revenue if
you cut the tax rate to thirty percent
you now have three thousand dollars in
tax revenue so your play is you'll cut
the taxes you'll lose a thousand dollars
in tax revenue but the economy will grow
so much that you'll add more than a
thousand dollars in tax revenue in the
end in order for that to happen with a
30 percent tax rate to recover a
thousand dollars in tax revenue
you need your economy to grow $3,300 so
the break-even is that the economic
multiplier on the cut money needs to be
3.33 if you give that thousand dollars
in tax cuts to the rich it is mostly
going to be saved because they don't
need that money and they are not going
to put it back into the economy in a way
that will have an economic multiplier
3.33 it just won't work if you give
$1,000 to the rich you're not gonna grow
your economy by $3,300 and the problem
is that it's not just Trump who supports
and believes this stuff lots of voters
support and believe this stuff they've
all been bamboozled and no one knows any
better than the president so I think
that this is a very very good piece that
you should check out and we're linking
to it on YouTube because it points out
that Donald Trump genuinely is furious
when he finds out what his policies will
do because he doesn't understand what
they will do there is one area where I
disagree with this piece which is that
it seems to take the position that Trump
has good intentions and he's just kind
of an easily manipulated [ __ ] I've been
very clear it's clear to me that Trump
has a policy his personal philosophies
political philosophy is one of self
aggrandizement and self enrichment and
greed period so while I think the piece
is very well-written and it points out
Trump genuinely does become surprised
when he reads about the impact of his
policies I don't think the guy has great
intentions I think his only goal is self
enrichment self aggrandizement and
patting himself on the back and we've
been seeing that in terms of this
horrible hurricane recovery so check out
the article think about this example and
let me know where I'm going wrong if I
am I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's remember of the day
is trips a plane trip thank you so much
for being a david pakman show member
this is viewer and listener supported
media we've had some ups and downs on
the show when it comes to funding over
the last six months or so but we've had
a lot of new people that were previously
not supporting the program financially
enter the world of supporting
independent media and i couldn't thank
you more including trip affleck you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership you can make
a contribution of as little as one
dollar a month at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and if you ever shop
on amazon.com please visit david
pakman.com slash amazon before you shop
because that will send us a kickback for
everything you buy let's talk about a
sort of I guess it's a First Amendment
story but it's kind of a second
Amendment story to set it up for years
I've been pointing out that so many
times you have what I call First
Amendment confusion you have people
typically on the right alleging that
someone's First Amendment rights are
being violated or alleging that
someone's free speech rights are being
infringed upon when really they're not
or even using the word censorship when
you're not talking about censorship
First Amendment arguments depend
directly upon the government infringing
or intervening in someone's ability to
speak and when we talk about free speech
more broadly a common misunderstanding
is that free speech means there can be
no consequences to one exercising their
freedom of speech and of course freedom
of speech is not freedom from the
consequences of that speech we have a
sort of I don't know if I want to call
it a boy who cried wolf scenario but we
have a situation that if taken at face
value would suggest some real actual
First Amendment concerns there's an
Indiana Republican congressman named Jim
Lucas who has drafted but not submitted
a bill and that's key here he has not
filed this bill and it's a bill that
would require Professional Journalists
to be licensed by
State Police they would have to submit
an application than the Indiana State
Police journalists would get
fingerprinted as part of the process
they would pay a licensing fee of $75 I
guess that gets you a lifetime license
to be a journalist and those with felony
or domestic battery convictions would be
prohibited from getting a journalism
license now you might be hearing me say
this and you're saying wait wait a
second
what constitutes being a professional
versus amateur journalist or what's a
journalist versus a reporter versus a
commentator or analyst or blogger
doesn't matter because this is not an
honest bill this is a bill that Jim
Lucas has drafted to try to make some
great point about the Second Amendment
basically what Jim Lucas is trying to
say is if you're going to require
licenses merely for exercising one
Second Amendment right to own firearms
then what about requiring licensing to
take advantage of the First Amendment as
well so it's rhetorical I get it Jim
Lucas is trying to make a point but is
this a good point in order to figure out
whether this point makes sense we have
to think about whether licensing for the
Second Amendment would in any way be
analogous to licensing in order to use
the First Amendment hint it's not a good
analogy the First Amendment specifically
says Congress shall make no law
restricting the freedom of the press as
well as other forms of speech the Second
Amendment says people can have guns it
doesn't say you can't require licenses
it doesn't mean you can have any gun
because if the argument is from someone
like Jim Lucas that the Second Amendment
is absolute and that would be implied by
this analogy to licensing journalists if
you believe the Second Amendment is
absolute then you have no reason to
defend not allowing the average person
to have an automatic machine gun or a
shoulder-mounted small missile launcher
or RPG as soon as you say no the Second
Amendment is not absolute in the sense
that we should have some regulation as
to what weapons or
firearms the individual citizen should
have access to as soon as you do that
then you were going into a gray area and
again the First Amendment says Congress
shall make no law the Second Amendment
doesn't say that the Second Amendment
doesn't prohibit any law abridging the
freedom of gun ownership it just says
there is a right to own guns gun
licensing doesn't infringe upon
someone's right to own a gun
even Antonin Scalia believed that laws
requiring licensing for guns were
constitutional the only part that does
prevent people from owning guns that
would infringe upon the Second Amendment
is the part of the law that says that
felons can't have guns but that's not
the part that Jim Lucas is taking issue
with it's the licensing part it's a
rhetorical bill that is absolutely
ludicrous by making this bogus analogy
between the Second Amendment and the
First Amendment but people are falling
for it there are people in Indiana I've
been reading on the Indiana subreddit
and Indiana news websites people love
this people think that Jim Lucas is
making some amazing political point here
he's not only someone who totally
misunderstands the First Amendment and
the Second Amendment could think that
I've been talking for a while about a
way that elected officials really
Republicans and Trump could damage the
Affordable Care Act without repealing
the Affordable Care Act and that is by
sabotaging it or sabotaging it to quote
William Shatner without actually
repealing it merely by defunding it okay
Donald Trump has now taken some steps to
do exactly this just before this recent
weekend Donald Trump has decided he's
going to get rid of the subsidies to
health insurers for low-income people to
help them pay for health insurance right
this will be one of those situations
that will not change the law but it will
change the ability for the government to
help people pay for insurance
Donald Trump is also going to allow for
even cheaper policies that will have
very few benefits
and few customer protections another way
that you are going to damage the end
consumer of health insurance and this is
so funny actually there's this guy in
the video if you're watching guy with
the mustache and the glasses over
Trump's right shoulder I know that guy
that's Dave Ratner he's the owner of
this retail chain called Dave's soda and
pet city out in Western Massachusetts
when I worked at Circuit City I sold
that guy some computers he was not known
as a right-winger in western
Massachusetts and he showed up behind
Trump when Trump was signing some of
this some of this nonsense and he is
getting crushed because Western
Massachusetts is so liberal and people
are furious that Dave Ratner is there
defending Trump signing of a bill that
is going to be terrible for people and
Dave Ratner now has issued some major
apology saying I'm not there because I
support Trump I've always wanted
employers to be able to buy insurance
across state lines or something I'm not
a bad guy and his business now is
actually significantly in danger I would
say not of going out of business but of
being damaged in terms of profitability
anyway that's Dave Ratner back to the
Obamacare stuff the idea here is what
the Affordable Care Act will stay but
premiums are going to increase because
now that the insurers are no longer
going to get government subsidies they
are going to have to make up for that
lost revenue by charging people more for
insurance it's very very straightforward
insurers are realizing that this is not
going to be good for them because when
they do have to raise premiums they're
going to lose some customers right and
they were expecting nine billion dollars
in the coming year they had nearly a
hundred billion coming to them in the
coming decade that they are now not
going to get this is spiteful disgusting
vile and it's an attempt to score
political points by hurting people and
lots of those people are Trump voters
President Obama warned us about this
others during the end of the Obama
administration warned us you know
without repealing Obamacare you could
defund aspects of it and I've been
talking about it for months but here's
the kicker Trump does this and it
Crash's health insurance stock prices
now I'm not taking a position on whether
that's good or bad I've said before if
we had single-payer health care it would
probably also be bad for health
insurance companies and their share
value but this announcement was bad for
health insurance stocks and Trump goes
on Twitter and brags about it
Trump took to Twitter over the weekend
and said health insurance stocks which
have gone through the roof during the
Obamacare years plunged yesterday after
I ended their Democratic Democrats
windfall number one days ago Donald
Trump was taking credit for the massive
stock market rally that we've seen
during the first seven eight months of
the Trump administration now Trump is
cheering that his actions have crashed
the stocks the stock prices of health
insurance companies from one day to the
next Trump has gone from stocks are
doing great and it's because of me two
stocks have plunged and it's because of
me and somehow both are good well which
is it both can't possibly be true but my
bigger question to Donny boy is if
you're okay with crashing health
insurance stocks if you're doing
something you feel is good for people
with health care why not just do
single-payer that's what would be the
best for people and it would also be bad
for health insurance stocks and you can
brag about it the way you're doing now
on Twitter I I don't understand the
logic behind this and it's probably
because there is no logic what I want to
touch on is how this will impact you
there's basically two parts here this is
part of the cost-sharing reduction
program part one is that insurance
companies have to give people on silver
plans whose incomes are under two
hundred and fifty percent of the poverty
line lower deductibles and co-payments
that doesn't change with what Donald
Trump is signed part two is that there
are budget items that give insurers
money to reimburse people or rather give
insurer's money to reinforce them for
having lower deductibles to low-income
people that's the part that Trump is
crushing part two part one is not going
to be touched
how much money could you make shorting
stocks if you knew ahead of time
what stunts Donald Trump had planned and
shorting stocks is basically it's a way
to you're basically borrowing stocks
with the idea that the price is going to
decrease and you can make money off of
the decrease of the value of a stock
imagine if Vlad Vladimir Putin who
according to some including Fareed
Zakaria is by far the richest person on
the planet even though he does a good
job of hiding his wealth
imagine if Vlad knew what stunts Trump
was planning a lot of money that could
be made about on that maybe we'll learn
about that someday the right likes to
say that they have a claim on patriotism
they have the monopoly on respect for
the military they support the troops
often by supporting whatever mission the
president wants to send them on if it's
a Republican or by putting a yellow
ribbon on their car the right decides
what is disrespectful and they've
decided it's disrespectful to peacefully
protest at a football game
by kneeling during the national anthem
and Donald Trump has been all over this
it's disrespectful to the flag to kneel
at a football game it's disrespectful to
the military donald trump has now
disrespected the flag by his own
standards Trump was at a Pennsylvania
Air National Guard base being
interviewed by Fox News's Sean Hannity
and during the interview retreat started
playing which happens when there is an
American flag lowering ceremony this is
a time when you're supposed to according
to US flag code stand and cover your
heart and look towards the flag and what
did Trump do he sat there talking to
Sean Hannity notices the song is playing
in jokes maybe it's being played for him
or if it's being played for Sean
Hannity's great ratings on Fox News if
you're watching this clip you'll notice
that as soon as the song starts people
in the background all stand and start
saluting the flag but not Trump very
disrespectful isn't it take a look and
GDP now I have to tell you for the last
quarter three letters Reaper sent three
two and actually three two they adjusted
upward what a nice sound that is are
they playing that for you or for me
they're playing that in honor of his
ratings did you see how good Israeli
he's beating everyone I think they'll be
higher tonight I'm just guessing so the
fact is that we really were really
rocking we have 3.2 now this yes
kneeling is disrespecting the flag it's
disrespecting our military and Trump's
it's during the flag lowering ceremony
as everybody else stands and it goes
further if you believe in the concept of
Flag respect when retreat is played for
a flag lowering ceremony you're actually
supposed to stand if you understand the
level of hypocrisy I'm actually going to
show you the flag code called conduct
during hoisting lowering or passing a
flag which says very clearly during the
ceremony of hoisting or lowering the
flag or when the flag is passing in a
parade or in review all persons present
in uniform should render the military
salute members of the Armed Forces and
veterans who are present but not in
uniform may render the military salute
all other persons present should face
the flag and stand at attention with
their right hand over their hearts that
is very very clear and Donald Trump says
that sons of [ __ ] should be fired
from the NFL because they kneel even
though there's no actual code for what
NFL players are supposed to do during
the national anthem and then Trump
himself ignores the actual flag code I
could not actually care less about this
nonsense but it is by these people's own
standards that they do everything they
accuse others of doing wrong Hillary's
emails they're all using private email
drain the swamp Trump is filling the
swamp so much that it's overflowing
kneeling during the national anthem is
disrespectful to the flag
they sit during an actual moment when
the flag code tells us what to do and of
course the bigger issue is that the NFL
players did it in protest Trump is just
ignorant there was no message behind
what he said are they playing retreat
for mere for your ratings Shawn there
was no message there other than I'm a
[ __ ] being silent and not moving in the
world of Trump is more disrespectful
than joking
about the music being played during a
flag lowering ceremony but remember
time when Obama saluted a service member
while holding a cup of coffee in his
hand that's really what's disrespectful
they've decided let's take a break david
patten.com slash read it discuss any or
all of these topics with us we'll be
back after the david pakman show at
david pakman.com welcome back to the
david pakman show I'm pleased to welcome
back to the program
David McAfee who's a religious studies
graduate a six-time published author
founder of the party of Reason and
progress and the new book is called no
sacred cows which deals with really a
lot of subject matter that we talk about
on the program so so first David you
have been studying and researching
everything from sects to cults to the
belief in the paranormal and religious
beliefs for a very long time so what
what made you want to look more
specifically at what you talked about in
this particular book I started studying
religion specifically when I was 18 I
started majoring in religious studies at
UCSB but it was a few years later that I
started realizing that there was this
gap in information about other
supernatural beliefs and people who
separated them so much and I just saw
any similarities between say
Christianity and it's supernatural
practices like prayer and then other
non-religious supernatural aspects and I
just was so curious to find more
connections between those two and so
that's what I set out to do yeah and
there's a number of studies which point
out I believe accurately that there is a
decrease in sort of devout religious
belief and also just more casual
association with organized religion but
at the same time you talk in the book
about how we're not seeing the same an
equivalent I guess we would say decrease
in belief in supernatural claims that
are outside of religious belief so first
how do we measure that and then we can
maybe get into some of the more common
beliefs yeah and that's exactly accurate
every study that I've seen every
reputable study that I've seen has shown
a rise in people who don't identify with
any particular religious tradition they
call it the rise of the nuns the the
unaffiliated people and so a lot of
people assume that that means that we
are seeing a lot more critical thinking
and people are thinking through these
things and deciding not to adhere to
these traditions but when you look at
other polls about belief in ghosts and
psychics and and other supernatural
beliefs that you would think would be on
the same tier they tend to be rising at
a pretty rapid rate and so that's why I
wrote this book was because I thought
that that needed the attention because
people seem to be under the impression
that they're always correlated and it's
really not true what would be a top-line
general explanation because on the one
hand we like to think that the reason
for the decline in religiosity is as
science develops and a sort of knowledge
of empiricism spreads through the world
it maybe eliminates the need or place
for organized or devout religious
beliefs but if that were the sole reason
or primary reason you'd imagine you'd
have fewer people believing in psychics
and ancient aliens as well exactly I
think the problem is that people aren't
necessarily thinking more critically
about all their beliefs they might be
pushing a religion away for any number
of reasons for one it's it's more
ancient than a lot of these beliefs it
ties into a specific dogma so with
ghosts and and other supernatural
beliefs there's not really this book
that bounds you to believe in and it
might be a push away from that away from
the rigidity of religion and toward the
fluidity of New Age beliefs and what are
the most common I mean you talked about
psychics and you alluded to some others
but when we're talking about
supernatural beliefs what's that what's
included there and what are the most
common I would say angels and demons
tend to be the most
common when I looked at poles it seemed
like even more people believed in angels
in the United States than identified
with Christianity from which you would
think that they would be getting the
angel concept but there's an entire
separate belief system there from people
who believe in angels but don't believe
in any religion they believe in guardian
angels or just some big concept that
they grew up with but it's true with all
of these different supernatural beliefs
we can name thousands of them and I do
in the book but I think the problem is
that people are just wanting to believe
in something bigger and they're moving
away from religion they need something
else to move toward that's not always
something supernatural but in many cases
it is in other cases it's conspiracy
theories which also factor in that same
idea that there's something greater
controlling everything well that was
what I was next going to sort of mention
which is the overlap in the sort of
processes that take place in someone's
mind that get them to the conclusion of
some supernatural belief or concluding
that a conspiracy theory is actually the
explanation for some phenomena in our
world rather than whatever the so-called
official story is do you believe that it
is the same sort of process that gets
people to those end conclusions I much
argue that in the book that the same
failing the same failures of critical
thinking lead to all of these different
false beliefs whether it's religion or
even these Colts or conspiracy theories
or other supernatural beliefs it's
because somebody didn't take the time to
think okay let's look at what has been
scientifically proven and then we
compare that to what what I want to
believe you got to separate your desires
you have to separate what your friends
and family have told you to believe
these are all influences that aren't
necessarily going to get you to the
right place but people trust their
family they trust their friends and so
if they're if they say that they saw a
ghost then you had a feeling ones that
you might have seen a ghost that belief
becomes solidified and there's not
really much that can change it it's
similar to religion in that instance
talk a little bit about both for this
book but also
in your past you've done some of this
some of what I guess I'd call them
undercover incidents or undercover
attempts to learn more about some of
these phenomena definitely this book was
kind of my biggest step in that
direction because it contains I think at
least 10 different interviews with
believers with psychics with members of
the Westboro Baptist Church with the
great-grandson of l ron Hubbard and and
not all of these interviews not in all
of them do I identify myself as a
skeptic I just basically asking
questions to these peoples and in this
book I decide to take it one step
further and I actually trained myself to
become a psychic to become a seer a cold
reader and I started performing on
Venice Beach and I went undercover in
that way and it really really opened my
eyes to how these beliefs are formed and
solidified because there were people who
were so convinced by my presentation
which was completely not magic of course
that they that they wouldn't believe me
when I revealed at the end that I was a
skeptic and that this was a thought
experiment they refused to believe me
they said that I was just trying to
cover myself so that the government
wouldn't come get me I I had people
trying to give me so much money and I
was like no these are completely free
readings I didn't take a dollar but this
one woman in particular just wanted to
give me money and I was like this must
be such an easy job for the people who
really do it and want to take money so I
mean I think that how long it takes one
to learn the skill of cold reading which
is sort of the underlying skill in what
is colloquially described as being a
psychic I think that depending on one's
emotional intelligence so to speak it
could take you more or less time to
learn those skills and to play off of
the reactions of the person you're
reading but can you tell us a little bit
about how long your training was and
what it consisted of yes so I've always
really been good at reading people at
reading their expressions on their face
and and guessing what they're thinking
based on that and I never really took it
the next step obviously to to pretend to
be psychic so this was
really really easy for me I would say I
read books for about two months before I
actually did my first live show and and
I would just practice even online I
would go on online chats and even just
seeing somebody's picture and talking to
them online I was able to guess things
like their name by just putting a letter
on the keyboard and then they'll say oh
that's that letters in my name and then
I can kind of figure it out from there
and I've also used warm reading hot
reading where you can research the
person who's in front of you before they
get there or while they're there there
are a lot of different tricks that I
used I would say about two three months
of total preparation and I didn't have
any dissatisfied customers um what are
some of the key books in your research
that you read Oh
psychic sciences is a really good one
that's from the point from the point of
view of believers of course but then I
also read a lot of books by James Randi
he has really done so much work on that
topic that there wasn't there isn't
anybody who's done more than him so I
read all of his books on the topic yeah
and it helped me out so much because I
was able to see how he exposed other
psychics and so I was able to learn from
those mistakes and when people tried to
expose me which did happen in quite a
few times I was able to anticipate that
and then make it even more impressive
for them really
so you said earlier that similarly to
religious beliefs that their it is
difficult to get people to critically
re-examine how they came to these sort
of supernatural beliefs can you give us
some of the better ways to try to get
people to re-examine those beliefs and
I'm sort of brought to the basic sort of
epistemology Socratic method of
questioning that we've heard from people
like Peter pegasion and others right
exploring how someone came to a
conclusion and what it might take to
change their mind are sort of the some
of the few inroads that we might be able
to make that's exactly right I talk a
lot in the book about the Socratic
method and how questions help people
understand these concepts more than
statements so if I were to tell you this
is how a psychic works
people are less likely to believe
believe me than if I said well how do
you think they came to this conclusion
why would this psychic say I'm feeling a
letter and and and then named the letter
why would a ghost or a spirit speak to
them in letters and fragments instead of
if they're really they're actually
speaking to them and and why is
everything so vague and and so when I
asked those type of types of questions
and it's not like anybody is like Oh
psychics are fake and all this stuff is
fake and walked away but it does plant
that seed of doubt and and that's really
what it's all about I also talked about
how to do all that while being extremely
nice it never helps or it rarely helps
to be confrontational and so I'm very
polite in all my discussions and I
really try to focus on the actual issues
to try to criticize with kindness as
Daniel Dennett has said and and it seems
to work very well that way the book is
fascinating we've been speaking with the
author of the new book no sacred cows
David McAfee he's a religious Studies
graduate six-time published author and
also the founder of the party of Reason
and progress David great job with the
book and thanks so much for talking to
us about
thank you very much for having me again
I appreciate it the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
we think sort of theorizing about how
dumb Donald Trump is and by dumb I mean
just sort of general knowledge we
figured out that after a year of
campaigning on health insurance he might
have the entire time actually been
thinking that it was life insurance we
speculated he might not have been aware
that Puerto Ricans were citizens until
someone told him hey you know these are
American citizens during the fall out
after the multiple hurricanes that hit
the Puerto Rican Island Trump's lack of
knowledge about what a blind trust is
was evident in the lead-up to his
inauguration how does the stock market
work how does money work is a stronger
weak dollar good for us something he
called Michael Flynn about at 3:00 a.m.
at one point
why didn't hurricane victims just get
away from the storm and their private
helicopters whatever right there's a
range of different questions we've
speculated as to Donald Trump's
knowledge on Donald Trump claimed over
the weekend while speaking to a hate
group that he met with the president of
the Virgin Islands of course there is no
such person or I guess there is it's
Donald Trump himself the the President
of the United States is the president of
the Virgin Islands effectively here is
Donald Trump at this horrible hate group
rally take a look we also stand with the
millions of people who have suffered
from the massive fires which are right
now raging in California and a
catastrophic hurricanes along the Gulf
Coast in Puerto Rico the Virgin Islands
and I will tell you I left Texas and I
left Florida and I left Louisiana and I
went to Puerto Rico and I met with the
president of the Virgin Islands these
are people that are incredible people
they've suffered gravely some of those
people are literally incredible in the
sense that they don't exist and we
shouldn't believe in them like this
other guy or gal who supposedly is the
President of the United States Virgin
Islands now how did the Trump
administration deal with this bogus and
embarrassing statement by Trump well
they corrected the transcript so that it
would say governor instead of president
after the fact they wrote the White
House released a transcript where it
says I left Florida and I left Louisiana
and I went to Puerto Rico and I met with
the president
this crossed out governor has been
inserted of the Virgin Islands every
single joke about Donald Trump becomes
the truth two weeks ago I joked Donald
Trump should demand the resignation of
the president of Puerto Rico over his
terrible handling of the recent
hurricanes and now Trump actually says I
met with the president of the US Virgin
Islands in the context of hurricane
relief
I spoke with myself about disaster
relief because I'm doing great things
for these poor people or something like
that here's Donald explaining why he's
the guy to go to with any issue we have
because he's such a smart guy and I was
a good student I understand things I
comprehend very well okay better than I
think almost anybody and I want to tell
you I listened to a bunch of stuff last
night on television that was disgraceful
it was disgraceful he listened to a
whole bunch of stuff something is very
wrong here beyond just being an
uninformed dude born with a silver spoon
in his mouth right remember when it
would have been surprising if the
president said something this dumb the
simpler times of is our children
learning and binders full of women or
what's Aleppo what what is that what's
Aleppo those were simpler quaint times
where now we are dealing with a whole
new level of incompetence and stupidity
from the President of the United States
there is a major major anti-vaxxer panic
over a total misunderstanding of a
vaccination situation I'm going to tell
you the story of Rebecca bread al who's
a Michigan mom previously Rebecca was
sent to jail for refusing to comply with
a court order that mandated her
nine-year-old son be vaccinated now you
might hear that and say a government a
court is mandating vaccinations for kids
well not exactly Rebecca used to have
primary custody of her son she was
released last week she was expecting to
be reunited with her son but not so fast
she has now lost primary custody which
will be split 50/50 with the son's
father during this period this
son also received four immunizations and
is now completely up to date with
vaccinations the mother Rebecca Brett ow
did not want her son vaccinated the
father did want her son vaccinated
anti-vaxxers are going nuts saying the
government cannot mandate vaccination
the government is not mandated
vaccination Rebecca
agreed as part of a court custody
hearing to have the child vaccinated in
deference to the wishes of the father
she agreed to that as part of a custody
hearing she has not done that and thus
was held in contempt of court the fact
that it is vaccinations is secondary the
issue is she agreed to this in front of
a court as part of a custody hearing and
she has now said after agreeing to the
vaccinations that she doesn't want them
because of her religious beliefs
she's never detailed her religious
beliefs that I was able to find and who
knows if that's just something she's
saying to try to prevent the
vaccinations but she has not been jailed
for not vaccinating her kid specifically
the kid is not being given partial
custody to the father because she has
not vaccinated specifically it's because
she violated the custody agreement that
she agreed to in front of a court and
she has fallen into contempt of court by
ignoring that and the anti-vaxxers are
going absolutely and totally crazy about
this now to go back for a second to the
religious exemptions thing most states
actually still have religious exemptions
for vaccination but it is not for any
purpose it is specifically if you want
your kids in public schools the
anti-vaxxers like to say government
mandates that kids get vaccines well no
no it's that government runs schools
public schools require vaccinations and
if you want your kid to go to those
schools which is by no means a necessity
then the kids need to be mat vaccinated
only California Mississippi and West
Virginia have removed exemptions
from school vaccinations for religious
purposes if you want your kids in those
schools then yes you are going to need
to comply and vaccinate them but you are
not obligated to do that I actually just
witnessed recently I was at a little
kind of fall gathering with some friends
ah and there were two people I know that
work in the medical field doing research
that's not directly related to
vaccination but it's kind of close and
an anti-vaxxer mom was there with full
indignation telling them they need to
look into the science more because she
knows the truth and they don't and it's
it's sort of it's an appeal to Authority
fallacy to say the people working in the
medical field are right merely because
they work in the medical field but the
idea that any random stay-at-home mom
who's homeschooling her kids to avoid
vaccinations knows more than people
actually working in the medical field
that I take issue with two one nine two
david p is our voicemail number here's a
voicemail accusing me of not knowing
that the word to legitimate is false
take a listen to this I just David
hunter from Lake Harmony Pennsylvania um
I just want to let David know that there
is no world legitimates the word is
legitimize legitimizes anyway my mighty
temptin yeah well those are your two
cents here's my two cents and that is
that I'm putting up on the screen for
you the dictionary definition of too
legitimate as a verb the adjective
legitimate means that it conforms to the
law or two rules but of course there is
a definition of the word spelled the
same way but it is pronounced legitimate
which is a verb and it is to make
legitimate to justify or make lawful for
example the regime was not legitimated
by popular support so David I appreciate
your two cents and I am returning those
two cents or at least a different two
cents of mind to you and telling you
that the word to legitimate as I used it
is correct and because of that I have no
time to tell you
but trust me folks it's a good
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]